[Applause]
happy Wednesday everyone so before we
get to the fun stuff I do want to talk
about the Nashville school shooting
don't worry the second half of the show
is really funny Brian Kilmeade will be
here to talk politics
interview with former FBI profiler Mary
Ellen O'Toole and she backs up something
that I've been ranting about every time
bad stuff like this happens she told the
Daily Mail that Nashville and pretty
much everywhere else should brace for
copycat events due to the inevitable
contagion effect caused by the media
adding quote threats increase in schools
Nationwide after a shooting has occurred
anywhere in the U.S
sadly evil seems to inspire more evil
it's the same reason they keep making
more Sex in the City movies
but the media helps
now she knows this to be true because
after the Columbine shootings in 99 the
FBI studied 18 previous school shootings
and found that the copycat influence was
real in all of them turns out Mass
Shooters are as unoriginal as they are
disgusting and why because info on these
fiends becomes instantly available in my
new detail and what do fiends share a
love for infant me it's why they keep
press clippings from previous Shooters
and also why they boast about the infamy
before it actually happens like the
Nashville shooter did
so the media incentivizes future mass
shootings by rewarding the present ones
I don't know how you can get any more
playing than that which brings me to
Nashville's coverage I hate it here's
the front page of the New York Post
yesterday the timeline of Terror shows
you minute by minute how the Carnage
unfolded complete with pictures of the
gunman looking like a gunman then you
get chilling final text messages from
the shooter you get photos of the
victims you get stories about the
shooter's parents is that enough well we
also got the body cam footage family
members of victims photos of the
classroom pre-rampaged did we need that
and this is just one paper multiply that
by thousands because it's not just the
post and hell I love the post they broke
the story on Hunter's laptop and it's
the most accurate source for what Kim
Kardashian's butt is up to
I don't know but this story is
everywhere USA Today Newsweek ABC News
CBS CNN NBC they all featured similar
takes on their home pages so it gets
Amplified online as well as the networks
as social media blasts it into every
single phone it's like Jimmy phela at
Fox News he's he's everywhere and I'd
like to apologize for that
so how long before there's another
shooting and where is the media
responsibility in this don't they know
the science it's there the FBI has been
saying this for 25 years the repetition
of minimal facts along with the
play-by-play reporting and visual
accompaniment amplifies the story which
informs the Deeds of future
in fact it can lead an all probability
to another shooting within weeks so the
only way you could stop this is to show
some responsibility in the reporting
right now the media functions like a
Mindless meter made and that's no
offense to meter maids after all they
did look the other way when I keyed
Jesse Waters Ferrari
but in a way reporters are often just
writing tickets doing the job necessary
right then and right there with little
or no moral responsibility for the
future and it's the same media who after
turning every shooting into a spectacle
of infamy then complains why does this
always happen well because evil exists
and you amplify it you dumbass you think
that repetition of the same old facts
doesn't matter why do you think we have
advertisers you think we ran the same
old freaking Snuggie ad every five
minutes because it didn't work
hell thanks to advertising I own 400
Chia Pets
I've seen them yep my suggestion adopt
what the World Health Organization
advises regarding suicides create
guidelines to reduce the media footprint
to reduce imitation shut down the
visuals and have all new info done by
press release No video no film no pics
and avoid prominent placement stop
repeating the same facts move on when
you run out it seems you need to make it
as boring as a book on tape like this
one
now
now you could cut these incidents in
half or more if the media had agreed to
do it but will they I keep pleading but
I fear there's just too much attention
and power to gain the media lives by the
ratings while everyone else dies by them
[Applause]
[Music]
zero to 60 and 3.5 sentences hosts have
outnumbered Emily Campagna
he's not the funniest DeVito but at
least he's taller writer and comedian
Joe DeVito
I thought I had tinnitus until she
stopped talking Fox News contributor
captive
and Gwyneth Paltrow skis down him for
practice
my massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion
start us
Emily I work in the media I feel like I
I'm not trying to uh criticize by by
co-workers or anything like that I just
wonder like why can't we dial this stuff
back what's holding us back and there's
nothing holding back what we're focusing
on there's nothing insane let's
constrict the coverage in general it's
saying let's not put the shooter's name
out there on the front page let's not
put their photo let's not publish the
manifesto let's not create a culture
around centering the criminal rather
than centering the victims everyone I'm
sure knows the shooter's name let's name
who actually died that day little Holly
Scruggs Evelyn Dickhouse at nine years
old she died pulling the fire alarm
What A Brave Little Hero at nine years
old William Kinney might kill Cynthia
Peake and Catherine Catherine Koontz who
died confronting the shooter right
Officer Collazo officer Engelbert they'd
Engelbert had just received an award for
precision policing and Collazo he was a
Marine Corps veteran
um and he had responded to the Nashville
Christmas Day bombing in 2020. those are
the names that people should Revere and
honor and remember those are the photos
that we should know and it's also you
know it permeates law as well that
unfortunately I have to say it but the
Larry Singleton bill in California
remember that was
um derived after the horrible kidnapping
and torture of Mary Vincent and that
resulted in there being no parole for
someone that tortures someone during
Commission of a sexual crime because he
was out basically five seconds later the
bill was named after him how was it
named after her Mary Vincent those are
the heroes that we should amplify so I
wholeheartedly agree with you that at
least you know the responsibility we
have with this position to amplify the
good to imply those whose memories
deserve to be be honored and to
absolutely extinguish those that have no
place here yeah you know
[Applause]
finally Emily says something that makes
sense
the amplification of positivity is the
one exception to the media my media
blackout in the sense that like the body
cam footage I think was valuable because
it showed cops doing a great job and
maybe that influences people
to become cops yeah as a and I think
it's also important to see the murderer
get murdered because I don't think Mass
Shooters actually Envision that right so
it's good that they see themselves get
killed yeah well it it's sad that ever
since Columbine
these losers become celebrities because
when you think of all the things it
takes to create something and it only
takes a little bit of effort from a
deranged person to destroy and and what
is worse to destroy than the lives of
children it's it's so horrifying and it
bothers me that when these things happen
no one learns no one's opinion changes
and it's like they have this stupid
tweet ready to go yeah we have someone
who went in and and slaughtered people
in in a Christian School and people are
arguing over well what pronouns are most
respectful to the murder right we need
to stop that nonsense and and I don't
know what the the remedy for this
sickness in our society is but we've got
young people they're doped up they've
been locked up they're getting
surgically chopped up and now we're
wondering why they don't see any meaning
and purpose in their lives and it's I
don't know what we need to do about it
but I think Emily made a good point look
to the people who ran toward the gunfire
look to the people who should be the
ones whose names remember that the cops
who went in there they didn't know what
they were facing but they had a job to
do to save lives and they went and did
it you know
Kat Joe hits on the thing I think that
just drives me crazy uh when when when
uh in the in terms of the media the
story itself is horrifying but the media
acts like they've never talked about it
before it's like and they have their yet
they repeat the same exact things that
has to happen when you when you have no
when you have the I don't know the
memory power of a goldfish
well you know I think that also if you
look at the media coverage you would
think that what happened is somehow a
divisive issue yeah it's not everybody
except for maybe those few Absolute
Total insane Psychopaths agrees that
this was just unspeakably horrific but
you know there's this narrative coming
that Republicans they just don't care
about kids uh and I can't speak for
Republicans because I'm not one but as a
second amendment supporter I can say
that it's you know we have a right to
bear arms it's not that you know the rep
or excuse me the military and the police
should not be the only ones allowed to
have guns which also drives me crazy
when people on the left say you know all
these things about cops but then they
also think that they should be the only
ones that are allowed to have guns I
explain that yeah
um and that's what it's really about and
um I
I might get it for this but I don't care
to any conservatives who might be saying
this suggests that trans people
shouldn't be able to have guns I know
it's only a few people but I would like
to really caution you about calling for
the government to ban entire groups of
people from their fundamental rights
I didn't I didn't I didn't anybody call
there's a fringe people and
um it's enough for me to say something
about it because once that starts
happening there's no stop to it
continuing tyrants do you agree that we
in a way and it's unintentional or maybe
it isn't we incentivize this for I I
guess I I don't know what you would call
it uh some I guess outrage economics you
know well there's no reason for you to
be in this by yourself so let me take
this off that way no one else gets
blamed for what I'm about to say it's
our fault it's your fault my fault we
watched turn it off we don't turn it off
yeah who's going to be the first Network
to say no right right you're going to
lose ratings you're going to lose
ratings okay
the only picture we should see is that
individual with a bullet in his chest
crying out for help as they slowly die
that should be the picture that's it
once
once the Killer is shot and dead their
story's over it's done that's it
then we talk about the victims then we
praise the the police or criticize the
reaction or talk about how we make soft
tart with it's hard again but that's it
that's but here's the problem the
ratings and I disagree with you and I
love your monologues the most brilliant
people man I know but you you put too
much faith in people sometimes they're
not stupid yeah they know exactly what
they're doing they know if they if they
have at least six different shows with
different angles on this killer people
are going to watch right and then the
other networks are going to go well
guess what we're going to have seven and
then there'll be eight and they'll keep
going back and forth and then Here Comes
punk ass politicians with their uh we
need to get rid of guns and oh we need
to work on Mental Health they don't give
a damn either because they're getting
checks from the lobbyists from the NRA's
from this that whatever side of the
fence you want so there's only one way
to do it you me we got to turn the TV
off when they start getting it the
ratings go down we go down because no
one's going to do a documentary No One's
Gonna Do a documentary on the little
girl her life how's it came up and she
pulled the fire along nobody but they're
going to do a documentary on on the
individual who shot it and here's the
deal the reports that covered it they
might get in the documentary too because
they get a best-selling book out of it
so they know exactly what they're doing
they're just they're just is
incomplacent and could care about other
people's feelings as a killer when it
comes to making a dollar and until we
turn it off this is going to keep going
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else